hello there i'm gav i'm dan we're the
slo-mo guys i'm a big fan of channels
such as electro boom and big clive
because they both seem to have an
absolute vendetta against the capacitor
yeah me too i hate them why do you hate
them well it means every time you have
to sort of power cycle something you
have to unplug it or turn it off for at
least 10 to 30 seconds oh like restart
your router in there yeah exactly
i've probably wasted about 15 minutes of
my life at this point on these guys i
could do with some of these actually my
super nintendo needs a new one
today we'll be overloading one of these
putting a few too many beans through it
and filming it with a phantom 7510 the
fastest phantom that currently exists at
the time of this recording when shooting
at the extremely high frame rates of the
tmx 7510 your exposure time is so short
you need an absolutely savage amount of
light to light the subject isn't that
right yeah i can barely even see you
so this is a 1000 micro farad capacitor
is that right that's correct it's 1 000
micro farad and it's
16 volts
i've become very used to this symbol the
little um lowercase u meaning micro
oh you do a lot in micro don't you it's
on air as well
all right i'm set to 80 000 frames a
second on this first one pretty wide and
our exposure time is six and a quarter
micro seconds
goes without saying don't do this at
home don't touch any capacitors of any
kind at home because
they can hold their charge for a long
time which would be quite dangerous
especially larger ones in tvs and
computers and things like that
the way i'm going to explode this guy is
by passing a voltage that's too high
over it now this one's rated to 16 volts
and the pressure's going to build up and
explode hence the goggles hence the
goggles i'm also going to hide under the
table yeah i'm going to hide under the
desk behind me i think that's fair
turning on
increasing voltage
now oh there we go
unplugged oh god
it's like particulates oh god a little
shot at the top
look at that
i don't really want to breathe that in
i'm going to blow it away a little bit
smoky
wow already yeah i didn't have to pump
up the volts very high like this was
only 16 volts and it went pretty quickly
oh
that seems like a vent at the top yeah
a little spewer little safety spew event
that is moving really quickly
we're at 80 000 frames a second just
looks like a steam train yeah but that
must be happening incredibly fast yeah
interesting discoveries
yeah so it seems that there's like a
breakaway area like a frag grenade
almost like an area that cross there
it's built to allow the pressure if it
builds up too high like if it
overcharges like what we're doing it
seems to just come out of the top rather
than build up in itself and explode yeah
it's a lot of uh it's not a safety edge
remember those lithium batteries we did
with like the the four vent holes in the
top yeah yeah exactly similar let this
stuff out
whereas some of the smaller ones uh i
think this is the largest one that
doesn't have one it's just got a flat
plate
so i'm assuming that potentially this
one is more liable to explode rather
than just sort of vent its guts out over
the top power's on
amping up the bolts now
went over it oh well i was right
goodness me
that was very different
yeah yeah i tell you when it popped i
was sat under the table and it's just
like this snow fell down
i was hiding over there and uh
well you'll see what i found
oh
what
it's like a rocket what yeah watch the
way that the material on the outside
bulges and then actually wraps around
the top half
it like shoots up and engulfs the top as
it all gets sent up with like a rocket
the outer wrapping is like really oh
that's some arc that was just an
architect oh right
and that's like stuff melting and
sparking it's like a firework plasma
explosion that was so cool you would
never think that that was on like a
millimeter scale no it's like a it's
like a firework isn't it yeah
it landed right there no way what are
the chances of that
triggered it and it went
wow can i touch it yeah you can see the
coil of material here yeah a very thin
membrane of of a conductive material a
plate and then there's your insulating
material here
oh yeah you like a bit of that yeah i
like about that
turning it on
voltage is cranking
now
oh that one's completely gone
not too bad on the lens
it's good it's moving up oh
it's like taking off something it's like
squidging up the wire
oh the bottom blew up wow
it's different every time it is isn't it
yeah
some other stuff happening
it looks like uh
almost
liquid when it initially explodes
doesn't it there's like definitely some
sort of liquid almost in there oh look
yeah something i spotted when i looked
at it afterwards
the wire melted
and broke look at it getting red hot
it's got red hot is that a flame under
there is it like on fire
oh look there's sparks and stuff like
that that was like full on plasma
oh yeah
you see this melted metal here
was one of the legs of the capacitor and
this is what it should look like
woof
woof that's power woof
so we've mainly been working with the
biggest sized one with the vent and the
biggest size one without
what's this one about this one's the
smallest size just to see if it acts
differently yeah i'm just going to see
if it has like some sort of different
properties to the medium and large might
have like
i tested it before
and it popped quite viciously the sound
was quite like powerful so sometimes
these little ones might pack a punch all
right i've changed frame rate to 187
500 frames a second bigger woof
okay we have introduced a fan
switch to the probe lens we're very
close up got a very bright light up
front
it's wobbling all over the place
well in slow-mo it won't move yeah i
know right i have to turn the voltage up
higher on this one let me know when
you're ready ready
power on voltage up
whoa
god what a bit of like flaming debris
fell down under the table
even though it's macro this
like it's so much smaller that it
doesn't look the same
what
happened there jesus
plasma
then there's like a flame here let's go
back to that swell it like expanded at
the bottom and then in the top it also
went like it was like it's like a ripple
like a yeah like a ribbon
it just exploded like a balloon and then
all this gump
that's what i saw falling to the ground
on fire
look you can see the blue in the flame
okay
right this is blowing out an exposure
time of 2.6 microseconds do you think it
looks like we're in space yeah like it
looks like space this is definitely what
i saw falling to the floor
when i was under the table look at the
spinning piece of metal debris like
molten a little bit of lava yeah
all right in order to calculate speed
pretty much exactly eight millimeters
long
eight mil long
turning on cranking up
oh oh another flame ball came down this
would be good i think that'd be a good
one yeah
yeah without macro it really shows its
true size it looks absolutely tiny all
right here it goes
oh so now you can much more clearly see
why it's inflating like that the gas is
releasing at the bottom but because the
wrapper is attached to the bottom it
just inflates there's like nowhere else
for the gas to go
so weird
and they're just arcing fireworks
like a power station exploded
look at that
all of these smoke trails look wicked
they were really cool
turning on cranking up
that completely lit up the room
really it went what i saw a massive
flash of light
all right i'd like to see it weaponized
all right
all right this is gav speaking to you
from the edit our mics weren't on for
the shot for some reason so we're going
to just recreate it here aren't we done
yeah yeah we'll do our best all right
okay oh oh there's peeing everywhere
oh it gives a hole
[Laughter]
okay we were temporarily without mics
there but
not to worry
like
where did the cap go because it's made a
hole is it is it in here do you think it
must be
it must have landed right in there
oh he's as well yeah right the bottom
look you can
see it here
there's the capacitor in the balloon it
was the hole it made there it must have
just shot right in with absolutely no
resistance yeah it's small enough that
it could just tear through that's wild
definitely didn't have the the umph to
come out the other side no i mean
there's like quite a bit of water in
there but i'm actually surprised it just
went clean through you know and the
balloon didn't split because the bloom
is pretty yeah pretty full
that was uh that was similar to what
happened on this morning
with scoff scopes notice you're standing
right i'm standing right behind you
right here
[Laughter]
yes i am
rockets in
it's like a meteor on a planet
yeah i just went in shockwave it's like
a meteor hitting the ocean and just
created it's still shockwave nothing's
come out yet
oh you can see there's tiny ripples all
the way around the balloon like
miniature capacity just like an asteroid
hitting the earth and now the water's
coming out
that took so long it's probably in the
other in the other side of the balloon
at this point
sparking away
i wonder if it's going to finish the
reaction before the water hits it
it's the water heading straight for the
no
and we're done
okay all right okay i think uh i think
let's keep the water away from the
electricity now and uh i think we're
done
i'll be honest with you
that was a lot more carnage than i was
expecting from such a minuscule little
thing
maybe the size of them how weird was it
when we were zoomed in
really tight it looked like you're in
space in here this was huge and it's
just eight millimeters long and there
was bits of metal hitting the ceiling
about 30 feet up yeah i was expecting
just like a cat but it was you know all
these like gas and gump and plasma and
arcing and all the stuff that just the
human eye is just like a puffy white
frame flash
i feel like we got some stonking looking
footage there we definitely needed the
faster camera didn't we yeah it's like
blues and purples and greens i couldn't
believe it yeah that's mental
i'll let you in a little secret now i've
been emailing with mehdi from
electroboom and it turns out he's bang
up for a collaboration no pun intended
so if you'd be excited about seeing that
let us know in the comments and he'll
come down from canada and bring some
goodies with him for us to film on this
exact camera let me just critique you
there yep
you should you should have said
i'm currently emailing him and you're
amped about it well where were you when
i was talking 16 seconds ago
damn
i messed it up all right hopefully you
enjoyed that video make sure you
subscribe if you like slow-mo
all the other stuff as well there's
buttons all over the place we'll see you
next time love you lots tata